le projet est dans toutes les têtes
depuis 20 ans longtemps au point mort
l'enfouissement de la nationale 10 à
bien démarrer un chantier préparatoire
en 2019 le début aussi des travaux
d'aménagement cette année avec la
création d'un mur de protection et la
destruction du pont marcel cachin près
de la mairie prévue cet été
le projet comprend le dénivellement de
l'axé routier qui coupe la ville en deux
la création de trois plateaux urbain et
de deux ronds points en entrée et sortie
de ville coût total estimé plus de 95
millions d'euros
comme dans d'autres communes c'est la
sécurité qui est au coeur des
préoccupations des habitants trappe
touché par la radicalisation avec des
dizaines de départs vers la syrie par le
trafic de stupéfiants et par les
règlements de comptes entre bandes la
mort du petit moussa en 2015 avait
grandement ému
la ville fait partie des quartiers de la
reconquête républicaine identifiés par
l'état depuis plusieurs mois la police
de sécurité du quotidien est déployée
avec deux unités de patrouilles à pied
au contact de la population trappe ou la
moitié des 33 mille habitants à moins de
30 ans 25 % en moins de 15 ans la
jeunesse est donc également un enjeu un
projet éducatif de territoire a été
défini et c'est un collège dit innovant
qui pourrait voir le jour sur place dans
les prochaines années
thématique dans la continuité répondre à
la problématique d'emplois dans la ville
où le taux de chômage s'élève à 19 % 5
points au-dessus de la moyenne régionale
25% de la population trappistes
vivraient sous le seuil de pauvreté
enfin trap est une ville qui a
énormément changé profitant d'un vaste
plan de rénovation urbaine de 350
millions d'euros les habitants veulent
encore plus de mixité dans le logement
de nouveaux projets de construction
pourrait voir le jour prochainement